[Music]
you know it's funny what I'm growing up
my whole life when I specially when I
was a kid people would stop me on the
street and say it kind of annoyed me but
they would say you've got the map of
Ireland on your face I have such an
Irish face and then you come through the
curtain and I'm very familiar with your
work big fan of yours and you have
sunshine or Miss Irish head is you just
have a big Irish head just like me and I
man instantly feel right at home as a
kid I had literally my head was so big
my brothers make fun of me my ears my
head here is my body and my nickname as
a kid was head stir and you know now
that we're about to have reveille my
wife is here somewhere we're about to
have our fifth kid and you know they're
my kids cuz their heads so big and II
also it helps on it helps on television
Andy has a massive head yeah well it's
true what's the story from your prom
with what do they do they had to make up
you the prom oh I was prom king and
there was a crown that I when they put
it on it was also it was like a lesson
in glamour the crown was just a ricotta
cheese tub fake jewels and you know red
means gone and only thing that would fit
yeah yeah that's great
now this is it fascinating you said you
have a big Irish family how many did you
have brothers and sisters yeah I have
four brothers and a sister and you know
it's I never in my wildest dreams
thought that you know 20 years ago when
I first came out here that I would I
would have a the career that I have the
beautiful wife that I have and now about
to have my fifth kid so it's a I'm a
very blessed guy that's for sure every
every picture
I've seen every picture I've seen of you
with your wife your hand is on her
pregnant stomach I think we have a photo
here yeah and it looks like yours at
4:00
yeah it looks more than moving the
number to do this every every that's the
joke or is that a gang sighs the joke is
now we're stopping at 5 because it would
be a little uncomfortable you know
wrapping my arms around here for six
yeah it look like I'm groping her kids I
have been groping right yeah but I love
that you're always on the on the belly
give it what number this is right this
is the production model yeah it's pretty
awesome do you think we're gonna set
you're gonna you're gonna because I have
two kids I'm one of six
I grew up drive six and then I have two
kids and I keep saying to my wife where
is everybody what happened I grew up in
a house where you'd walk into the
bathrooms to meet someone you'd never
met that's right
just people running around all the time
people spilling out of closets and then
oh that was growing up in Boston that's
yeah I was like yeah but you know we
both grew up there and you know everyone
had five six seven eight kids right you
know and you know times have changed
obviously quite a bit but in Los Angeles
it's a lot less than having five kids
it's quite a bit out here but it's a
it's phenomenal and and also well out
here if someone has three kids people
act like they're insane except what are
you Hillbillies you know oh yes